First, to get something on screen,
even if it's not the latest data,
will pull data from the Cache.
Like service workers themselves
getting data from the Cache object
is a progressive enhancement, so
we need to check if the Cache's object
is available in the global scope.
If it is, we'll read the cached
weather data from there, and
get something on screen
as quickly as possible.
Next it's time to get the weather data
from the API with an ajax request.
If you're feeling adventurous try
using the new fetch API, but remember
you'll probably need to poly fill it so
that it works in all browsers.
When they getForecast method fires,
it now makes two asynchronous requests.
One that will try and
get data from the cache and
one that will try and
make an ajax request.
If there's data in the cache it
will be returned extremely quickly,
usually within tens of milliseconds.
Then when the ajax request
responds the card will be
updated with the freshest data
direct from our weather API.
Perfect.
Well okay not quite.
There is a potential race condition.
What happens if the network
responds before the cache?
When that happens the latest
data from the network could be
clobbered by the older cached data.
For a weather app that's
probably not a critical problem.
You might be caught without an umbrella,
or you'll wear shorts on a cold day.
But what about time sensitive
data like stock prices or
a spreadsheet with financial data?
In this case it's important to have
a flag indicating that there is
a network request pending and
only use the cache data if
the network request is still pending.
That ensures that if the XHR responds
faster than the cache, the flag will
prevent the cache from overwriting
the latest data from the network.